ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video oggi
parleremo di acconciature terribili e
tagli tremendi e dove trovarli non
proprio cioè si ci sono delle cose
abbastanza tremende
ci sono anche delle cose che non stavano
così male di cosa sto parlando della mia
hair story a grande richiesta infatti mi
avete chiesto di parlarvi di tutti i
miei cambi di look per quanto riguarda i
capelli quindi le tinte che ho fatto se
ne ho fatte le acconciature se tenevo i
capelli mossi se tenevo i capelli ricci un po
appunto la storia dei miei capelli prima
di partire col video mi raccomando se
non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
mio canale e cliccate sulla campanella
per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte
che pubblicherò un nuovo video partiamo
con le prime due foto chi è questa
bambina ricciolina ero io ovviamente
quindi per chi non lo sapesse io ho i
capelli ricci da piccola gli avevo
riccissimi nel senso che mia mamma mi
racconta sempre che mi svegliavo al
mattino ovviamente avendo sudato
durante la notte con li chiamava i
fusilli cioè propri ricciolini piccolini
stretti quindi proprio una sorta di
capelli afro
poi ovviamente crescendo e stirandoli
non sono non hanno più quel riccio però
come potete notare avevo proprio i boccolini sembravo un angioletto
in realtà ero una piccola peste chiusa
parentesi
quindi passo un'infanzia da riccia
un'infanzia che purtroppo ha
attraversato anche un momento traumatico
per quanto riguarda i capelli preparate
i fazzoletti per questo evento ve lo
dico già non c'è una foto perché facevo
poche foto in quel momento della mia vita e adesso capirete il perchè mia mamma mi
porta dal parrucchiere che c'era vicino
davanti alla mia scuola niente dovevo
accorciare leggermente i capelli e mia
mamma ai tempi aveva un caschetto un
carré non mi ricordo comunque arrivavano
piú o meno qua e io dolcissima proprio un
angioletto guardo la parrucchiera e dico
guarda io li vorrei come la mamma
la parrucchiera che evidentemente aveva
la giornata no oppure aveva voglia di
tagliare io non sto scherzando ragazzi
mi ha fatto i capelli a spazzola a
spazzola cioè io ero un maschio un bambino inizialmente non mi rendevo bene conto
di quello che fosse successo col passare
dei giorni con i compagni che mi
prendevano in giro che mi chiamavano
maschiaccio
io che comunque amavo legarmi i
capelli farmi le acconciature non potevo piú fare
niente di tutto ciò ho iniziato
veramente a soffrire di questa cosa e
per me lo dico sempre è stato il mio
primo vero trauma
cioè io per tot anni non sono più voluta
entrare da un parrucchiere perché avevo
la fobia delle forbici c'è sempre il luogo
comune delle donne insomma che non
vogliono farsi tagliare più di tanto i
capelli però immaginatevi una bambina
che passa tre anni della sua infanzia
con i capelli da maschio c'è magari gente
a cui piace ovviamente però io volevo
averli lunghi o comunque fino alle spalle
e invece per un errore nel parrucchiere
mi sono ritrovata ad avere i capelli a spazzola
va beh essendo riccia una volta che i
capelli hanno iniziato a crescere
stavo ancora peggio perché avevo questi
ricciolini a metà sospesi nell'aria
insomma ragazzi vi dico la verità per 2-3
anni mi sono vergognata tantissimo dei
miei capelli fino a quando insomma mi sono arrivati più o meno qua sopra le spalle
ed erano gestibili però veramente è
stato forse il periodo più brutto della
mia vita
dopo di ciò più o meno alle medie ho
iniziato forse anche per questo trauma
che avevo subito a voler cambiare quindi
non mi volevo più vedere riccia andavo
con la mamma dal parrucchiere me li facevo
stirare anch'io
oppure ai tempi andava di modissima
farsi il frisé con la piastra frisé
quindi cosa facevo la piega liscia e poi
due ciuffetti qua ha fatti col frisé cioé
una roba proprio una pacchianata senza
senso però io uscivo al parrucchiere mi
sentivo top in questo computer non sono
riuscito a trovare più di tanto su
questi periodi che vi ho appena
raccontato ma ho trovato questa foto
questa foto risale a una delle mie prime
serate in discoteca se non la prima la
seconda sicuro aprirei una parentesi
lunga due ore sull'outfit ma questo è
tutto un altro video mi concentrerei sui
capelli liscio piastrato già ai tempi
insomma amavo e lisciarmi i capelli e
sicuramente per tutto il periodo del liceo
la maggior parte dei giorni avevo i
capelli lisci cioè me li lasciavo molto
poco ricci questa foto invece risale
all'estate se non sbaglio della
maturità
quindi io selvaggia io molto chiara
quindi questi colpi di sole non so cosa
erano comunque ero molto chiara sulle
punte soprattutto riccio selvaggio
periodo durato poco perché poi è
subentrata la schiaritura proprio
definitiva il biondo il mio primo biondo
totale cioè non erano più solo dei colpi
di sole era proprio biondo aprirei una
parentesi su quanto guardandomi adesso
mi veda insomma stranissima non mi
piaccio però ai tempi mi piaceva questa
foto è di un backstage di uno shooting
che avevo fatto questa qui é una foto
appunto di scena lì insomma di questo
shooting notare il tatuaggio sparito
completamente riccia e bionda non mi
piaccio poi mi farete sapere voi nei
commenti come stavo
quest'altra foto è sempre del periodo
del biondo da notare i carriera bianchi
che avete già avuto modo di conoscere
nel video sulla mia collezione di
occhiali
questo è stato forse l'unico giorno in
cui lo indossati e poi li ho buttati
anzi non li ho buttati perché ce li ho ancora vabbè in senso
metaforico non li ho piú messi
rullo di tamburi
questa è sempre bionda il mio periodo
del biondo ma io parlerei di questa
acconciatura di quella che io chiamo la
cofana la cofana è stato un leit motiv
della mia vita per quanto riguarda i
capelli perché prima o poi con vari colori
tinte capelli ricci capelli lisci la
cofana c'era sempre
e voi vi chiederete perché soprattutto
magari i ragazzi più giovani che non
hanno vissuto quegli anni in cui c'era
fergie dei black eyed peas che dettava
le regole della moda perché perché lei
aveva questa pettinatura e la maggior
parte delle ragazze che
venivano a scuola con me si facevano questa pettinatura molto facile
se volete vi faccio un video tutorial
si prendevano i capelli così si cotonavano
o comunque si portavano tutti in
avanti si metteva una bella pinzettina
qui è più alta era più figa eri capito
come potete notare l'ho preso alla lettera
perché sembro un gallo un gallo cedrone
benissimo nera abbronzatissima erano
lampade che ai tempi insomma ne abusavo
quest'altra foto sempre bionda ecco qui
subentra un'altra colonna portante della
mia vita della vita dei miei capelli
le extension le extension che io conservo
tuttora potrei fare un video solo su
quello di tutti i colori di tutti i tipi
di tutte le tipologie di capelli ricci
liscio mosso striature meches qualsiasi
cosa ne ho per ogni persona cioè
potrei aprire un negozio
queste in particolare erano bionde come
potete vedere dello stesso colore
dei miei capelli perché
spesso andavo in giro anche con colori
diversi perché direte voi perché non
trovavo il colore che avevo in testa e
quindi insomma cercavo di
abbinarle così a sentimento questa
sempre con le extension bionde
lunghissime cioè mi arrivavano
praticamente quasi al sedere
questa sempre biondo ma mi sembra un po più giallo quindi già qui forse col sole
dell'estate si iniziavano a ingiallire che cosa
è successo cosa è successo quell'estate
nov vabbè aprirei una parentesi su questa
foto dove ho la cofana la coda finta che
si attaccava qui e le lenti a contatto
grigie ho preso 20 anni in questa foto
sembro una quarantenne qui una cofana
con una ricrescita veramente
pazzesca sempre la cofana di lato con i ricci
così un po concettuale poi questa ecco
questa volevo arrivare a questa foto
quindi qui c'era ciuffo stirato riga di
mezzo ciuffo portato di qua cofana
cerchietto sottile sottile qui giusto per
far capire la differenza tra ciuffo e
cofano e coda finta mossa qui ero a
gallipoli che cosa è successo a
gallipoli mi ero tinta i capelli appunto di
biondo già mesi prima insomma
dell'estate con il sole sapete il biondo
bisogna curarlo molto perché già
schiarendo il capello si sfibra quindi sotto il sole devi mettere il protettivo
eccetera eccetera io avevo lavorato in
puglia 1-2 mesi sotto il sole quindi il
biondo era diventato veramente paglia fieno giallo tremendo tornata da
gallipoli non contenta che avevo tre peli in
croce come capelli mi metto le extension
cucite quelle che si fanno le ragazze di colore cucite
qui dietro con le trecce mi avevano
fatto di un colore più
chiaro dei miei capelli quindi sopra le
extension mi sono fatta un'altra tinta
bionda ragazzi
quello è stato il baratro perché io non
avevo più capelli in testa adesso ci
scherzo su ma è stato quasi pari a
quando da piccola mi hanno fatto i capi
a spazzola perché
facevo la coda tanto così di
coda non sapevo come fare disperata e da
quel giorno ha detto basta basta extension
basta tinte adesso devo curare i
miei capelli
in questa foto potete notare insomma il
cambio radicale cioè i miei capelli
sono tornata insomma al mio colore
naturale ho iniziato a scurire per tornare
ad essere castana tagliati perché avevo le
punte devastate quindi come potete
notare mi arrivavano tipo alla spalla
dalla faccia non ero molto soddisfatta
però dovevo fare qualcosa perché i miei
capelli veramente cadevano a pezzi
quindi inizialmente stirandoli ovviamente
mi arrivavano qui utilizzavo le mie
solite code quindi in questa foto per
esempio potete vedere che ero scusa qui mi facevo la cofana e poi qua la
codina micro che avevo la nascondevo
nel codone di extension finto che ho
infatti in questa foto biondo quindi era
un effetto un po shatush che ai tempi
andava molto di moda
ho riiniziato anche a tenerli
più spesso ricci sempre con l'aiuto
delle extension queste erano extension
ricce a clip
lasciamo stare il mood l'outfit molto
ghetto ma ero in quel mood in quel
periodo
piano piano ovviamente i capelli
crescevano qua avevo sempre le extension
però i miei capelli mi ricordo in questo
periodo qua che erano già più o meno sotto le
spalle qui ero in sardegna e notare la
bravura avevo fatto le trecce con le
extension a clip quindi avevo diviso le
extension a clip avevo nascosto bene le
clip dietro e mi ero fatta queste trecce
proprio io ormai professionista del
capello poi qui apriamo la parentesi
ramato c'è stato un periodo che è durato
poco però in realtà mi piaceva molto
come mi stava questo colore
mi ero fatta un po più rame e quindi con
questi riflessi un po più rossastri qui
sempre riccia già mi erano
cresciuti come potete notare e erano
ritornati le lenti grigie
quindi questo accostamento che devo dire
non mi stava male come colori
qui ero a una festa di halloween se non
sbaglio o di carnevale non mi ricordo
sempre con la lente grigia ormai era
fissa
e li tenevo ricci con un pó
di ramato a me piaceva abbastanza potrei
ripensarci
qui ovviamente ritorna la cofana
perché come ho detto prima la cofana
c'era sempre e castana quindi qui avevo
la coda finta castana mi ero gellata
bene i lati e la mia amica cofana ed ero
tornata insomma del mio colore
qui era il mio ventesimo compleanno
avevo sempre la coda finta ma qui ecco
questo è uno degli episodi in cui la
coda era più chiara del resto dei
capelli e si nota abbastanza
soprattutto col flash magari di sera
speravo che si vedesse poco però col
flash puntato si vedeva rivedibile
insomma ecco diciamo che non era
uno dei look migliori chiudiamo la parentesi
del castano perché rullo di tamburi
bionda mi son fatta bionda rame mi sono
fatta rame castana é il mio colore all'appello cosa manca
il nero bravissimi mi sono fatta
nera che si dice mora in realtà io non
mi soffermerei più di tanto sul colore
insomma sullo scuro ma sul taglio
perché io mi chiedo che problemi avessi
con i parrucchieri chi mi ha tagliato i
capelli in questo modo cos'è che
taglio è vabbè comunque erano molto
corti quindi secondo me di nuovo le
extension mi avevano un po sfibrato il
capello stressato il capello quindi di
nuovo ci avevo dato un taglio però non
stavo neanche male con questo scuro qui
anche scuri però qua mi sembra avessi le
extension
qui invece ero sempre scura ma col
cappello mosso qui ero già a milano
ero già all'università se non sbaglio
anche così mi piaceva molto
e qua di nuovo extension
riccia extension questo look proprio super
hiphopparo
ovviamente è una foto di una serata hip
hop quindi era un molto nel mood e extension
tremende perché sembrano veramente
di plastica non so dove le avevo recuperate
qui il lo scuro iniziava a scaricarsi un
pó quindi stavo tornando piuttosto
castana sempre extension ma a clip e questa
è una bella foto che mi avevano fatto in
uno shooting questa foto mi fa morire
dalle risate perché allora io la mia
base é scura castana evidentemente mi
ero fatta dei riflessi sulle punte
pó più chiari e sotto avevo le extension
tipo biondo scuro quindi senza volerlo ho
creato tre sfumature sui capelli che
sono quelle che adesso vanno di moda
perché vedo un sacco di gente che ha
tre colori ma ovviamente colori
più sgargianti come rosa viola eccetera
eccetera
io ho anticipato la moda perché
rimanendo sul castano altro che shatush io
ho fatto lo step successivo cioè castano
castano chiaro e punta bionda qua
veramente top poi anche lì aprirei una
parentesi sull'outfit ma questo potrebbe
essere un altro video gli outfit della
mia vita
fatemi sapere se lo volete
che dire maryners e maryners
allora conclusione finale
ci sono insomma dei look che non mi
piacciono che non rifarei ci sono dei
look che effettivamente mi stavano
abbastanza bene voi probabilmente da
quando mi conoscete perché da quando ho
iniziato a fare i video non ho mai
cambiato più di tanto il mio
colore di capelli quindi queste cose vi
spiazzeranno perché tanti di voi magari
non avranno la minima idea del fatto che
io per un periodo della mia vita ero bionda
gialla direi ovviamente fatemi sapere
cosa ne pensate spero che questo video
insomma vi abbia fatto divertire e che abbiate scoperto un lato di me e soprattutto
quello del trauma di quand'ero bambina
perché ragazzi veramente mi ha segnato
mi ha segnato ogni volta che vado dal
parrucchiere a spuntare più di tutte le
altre donne ho l'ansia perché sono
rimasta traumatizzata e detto questo se
avete qualsiasi tipo di domanda consiglio
eccetera eccetera
scrivetelo qui sotto io vi mando un
bacione ci vediamo al prossimo video
ciao ciao adoro